PATRICK MECHURA: Thanks
for coming today, guys.
You're at "Quick
Wins: Leveraging GCP
for Rapid Prototypes."
As mentioned, my name's Patrick.
I'm a technical business
analyst here at Agosto
on the advanced services team.
By my side here,
I've got Ray Pitmon.
He's our solution architect,
also with the advanced services
team.
If you're not
familiar with Agosto,
we're a tier 1 GCP partner.
We are located in
Minneapolis, Minnesota.
That's where our HQ is.
If you have any
questions about Agosto
or you just want
to learn more, feel
free to stop by our booth, 1321.
It's got the big red A above it.
So pretty easy to spot.
Moving along.
So today, what are we
going to talk about?
We're going to talk a little
bit about some of our customer
stories.
What do they do?
What issues did they have?
And how did we help
them solve those issues?
After that, we're going to
review some of the architecture
trends.
There's really two
different use case,
two different types of projects
that we're going to review.
So we're going to look at
the architecture trends
amongst those types of projects.
We're going to hand
it off to Ray then.
He's going to review some
of the common services
that we're using on
these rapid prototypes.
Before I move on
here, though, I just
want to get a quick idea of
where everyone in the audience
is at with GCP.
So, I guess, the first question,
who knows what GCP stands for?
OK, good.
We're off to a good start.
So who's using GCP in
production right now,
or you're well on your way?
OK, cool.
Good.
How about if you're
evaluating GCP?
Maybe you're on your way,
but still kind of new.
Couple of hands.
All right, cool.
Good.
Got a mix of people here.
So that's good.
Last question.
So some of you might know 12
animals of the lunar calendar.
I don't know if anyone's
familiar with that here.
How many of you
know what year 2019
is, what animal it represents?
The year of the pig.
So once we learned that,
coming from Minnesota,
we couldn't pass up the
opportunity to talk about one
of our favorite clients and
their internet-connected pigs,
a project that we more
affectionately refer
to as the Internet of Swine.
So you might be wondering,
why would someone
want to connect their
pigs to the internet?
It seems a little bit weird.
We thought it was a
little bit strange
when we first were approached
with this opportunity.
But see, our client
is an ag tech company.
And they saw an
opportunity to help
farms improve their efficiency
and increase revenue.
They knew that they
spend a lot of time
monitoring the health of pigs
for reproductive reasons.
And they're also very
prone to get sick.
So, if they could
track their activity
and build a predictive
data model around it,
they could help the
farmhands save time.
So they had a hardware
team that managed
the embedded development.
So I'm going to review
the hardware here.
They brought us
in to really help
with the cloud infrastructure.
So we're going to look at
the app architecture right
after this.
But just so you understand
how the data was
getting to the cloud, let's
take a look at the hardware.
So first we've got the ear tag.
The ear tag was attached
directly to the pig.
It had an accelerometer in it.
And that accelerometer
tracked their movements
so that they could tell if
they were sitting, standing,
laying down, all of the above.
It would also collect
the beacon information,
which is the middle there.
So the beacons were placed
in the feeding troughs
and in the water reservoirs.
And they would emit a signal.
And the ear tags would
measure that RSSI.
And if it got close
enough, it would then
collect the beacon
information and send it up
to the Raspberry Pi, which
is the third item there
on the right.
That was just hung in
the rafters of the barns,
connected with the ear
tags via Bluetooth,
and then acted as a
bridge up to the cloud.
So now that you understand how
the data was getting there,
let's look at what we did
once it was in the cloud.
So as mentioned,
got the pig here
representing the ear tags
connecting to the Raspberry Pi
with Bluetooth.
The Raspberry Pi was then
transmitting the data
into the cloud using
an MQTT bridge.
So initially that was with
RabbitMQ and a custom-built IoT
adapter that Agosto developed.
Nowadays, that's
replaced with IoT Core.
So once the event data is landed
in Pub/Sub, or in the cloud--
excuse me--
we throw it into
a Pub/Sub topic,
which can then be
consumed by GKE,
Kubernetes Engine in this case.
Kubernetes then did
some data transformation
and wrote it to BigQuery for
some additional analytics
and their data team
to be able to pull
out and do some
visualization tools
and build their data models.
You also see Datastore up there.
That was just a simple
backup storage in case
there was any errors
writing it to BigQuery.
We stored the raw event
data in Datastore.
The last thing here
that I want to touch on
is just the power of Kubernetes.
I'm sure you guys have
heard about it all NEXT.
But once we got
this up and running,
we really found out quickly
that one pod was not
going to be enough
to handle hundreds
of devices coming in
per second from all
of the pigs in the barn.
So we were able to make
a quick config update,
scale it up to three pods--
that was just for
one deployment--
to be able to spread out the
workload across all those pods.
Ultimately, this is kind of
what their visualization started
to look like.
They pulled it out and were able
to tell when they were sitting
and both when they
were drinking,
amongst a wide breadth
of other data models
that they were able to
successfully build around
reproductive and, like,
if they're nesting,
if they're ready to give
birth, things like that.
So in just over two weeks,
they were able to get up
and running successfully
from the barn
all the way to
the cloud in order
to build their data models.
So it's pretty quick.
And we were able
to do it leveraging
those cloud native services.
So that's just one
example of IoT.
We're going to look
at another one here.
It's a little bit different
than monitoring pigs.
So this is a manufacturing
and technology company.
And this manufacturing
and technology company,
they have a series of devices
that help organizations
of all shapes and sizes manage
and monitor their inventory.
One example is
actually the badge.
They have some printers.
So they help print the badges
on your NEXT certificate,
or your NEXT badge this week.
So in order to help them
manage that inventory,
they wanted a
scalable IT solution.
Again, they had the
manufacturing down
and their own development
teams that were managing
the firmware on this hardware.
But they needed something
scalable and in the cloud.
So here we come with GCP.
Over just three weeks, we were
able to get this architecture
up and running.
It was initial PoC in
which, once we were actually
wrapped with this,
they selected GCP
as their cloud
provider of choice
because we were able to prove
out that it can scale rapidly
and to the size that they need.
So again, very similar
to the pigs here,
we've got the device on the
left-hand side communicating
with IoT Core via
an MQTT bridge.
From that MQTT bridge,
we landed in Pub/Sub.
Instead of GKE here,
we have it being
consumed by a Cloud Function.
So it's just another
compute option.
I'm sure you guys have
heard Cloud Functions.
And then landing it in
BigQuery for a data warehouse.
After they selected
GCP, we added
some additional functionality.
So this isn't within
the three weeks,
this extra functionality.
But you can see it's kind of
a daisy chain, Pub/Sub, Cloud
Functions.
And what it's essentially
doing is doing a lookup
into Firestore, which is
where they were storing
some additional ancillary data.
And if there was filter related
to that event that came in,
they would land it in a Cloud
Function, apply those filters.
If the filters were
passed, then he'd
throw it in another
Pub/Sub queue
to then eventually
notify this webhook.
And the webhooks were dynamic.
So it could be an infinite
number of webhooks.
One example our customer used to
demonstrate to their customers
was changing a Philips
hue light bulb color.
So from red to green
to blue to you name it.
So that's two examples
here of two different IoT
architectures.
Pretty different use cases.
So you might be wondering,
how does this help you?
And if you don't have
an IoT architecture,
it might not directly.
But when you start to strip away
some of the specific tools that
are being used and you
genericize these app
architecture, you can start
to see some of the trends
that we're talking about here.
So moving forward here, back
to the Internet of Swine,
we've got IoT Core,
and you've got Pub/Sub.
So IoT Core and Pub/Sub are
acting as your ingest and event
queue.
From there, you've got it
landing in the Compute.
And then BigQuery is for
analytics, data storage,
your backup storage.
If we compare this to the
inventory and operations,
got IoT Core and Pub/Sub.
They're acting as your
ingest and event queue.
Cloud Functions is your compute,
and BigQuery is your analytics.
Looks pretty similar.
So, when you start
to map that out,
you can draw a generic
diagram of this nature.
So you've got your IoT
devices, whether it's
a light bulb, a speaker, a
tablet, a gateway device,
communicating to the cloud.
Could be MQTT, could be HTTP.
All of the above work.
Lands in, typically, IoT Core,
to then be consumed by Pub/Sub.
Once it's in Pub/Sub,
it can be consumed
by any of those compute options,
Cloud Functions, App Engine,
Compute Engine, Kubernetes.
And then land it in
storage and both analytics.
Usually for analytics,
we're seeing BigQuery.
It's a very powerful tool.
A lot of customers want
to get their hands on it.
Moving on to our
next set of projects,
this is analytics and
ETL-style projects.
So we're going to
talk a little bit
about some of the trends
we're seeing among those.
So the first ETL
customer, they come to us
as a Fortune 500 retailer.
They have their
online shopping model,
like all Fortune
500 retailers do.
They have an option
to ship from store.
So their customers, when
they're checking out,
they can ship from store.
And when they're
shipping from store,
they can get it at
an expedited rate.
But the tough part
for our customer,
they didn't have a way of
tracking whether that order
remained profitable for them.
So they came to us with the
ask of helping them define,
how can we determine if
these ship from store orders
are profitable?
So this was a little bit longer.
You can say it was three months
instead of in the weeks range
that some of the
IoT projects were.
It's actually because
our data scientists,
they took a data dump of all of
their orders for a year or two,
used Datalab to essentially
analyze all the data
and build an algorithm to help
determine if it was profitable.
So once we were able to
propose that to the client,
the client approved it.
And we were able to get moving
on the actual architecture
itself.
So let's take a look at what
that architecture looked like.
So as I mentioned, you've got
the online ordering system.
So as soon as the
customer placed an order,
they landed it on
a Kafka server.
From there, we used
a Pub/Sub connector
to land it in Pub/Sub.
And the reason that
we didn't bring it
straight to Dataflow,
under certain environments
you certainly could do that.
This specific customer
had a firewall
that we just couldn't bypass.
So we landed it in
Pub/Sub with the connector
as a way to get
it into Dataflow.
So from there, Pub/Sub consumed
the messages off the topic,
ran its ETL job--
in this case, the algorithm
that our data scientists
had created in
the initial phase.
And then we land it in BigQuery
for their analytics team.
And their business users
then consumed it via Tableau.
So after about three
months, this retailer
went from not being able
to determine whether or not
an item was profitable
to being able to turn off
the ship from store item
option on their online shopping
store for those items.
Next company here
for ETL we're going
to talk a little bit about.
It's a medical device company.
They're located in
Minneapolis, Minnesota.
They have a companion
app that they've
published for their
medical device,
helps the users
configure and monitor
the activity on their device.
And so they actually built
this with Firebase to get it up
and running quickly.
They use Firestore and Cloud
Storage on the back end.
And as their research and
development team started to see
the data coming in from the
users-- all the usage data,
diagnostics--
they realized that there was
a big opportunity for them
to improve their users'
experience by looking
at that data.
What they ended up
doing was coming to us
because, in the medical
industry, there's HIPAA.
And your R&D team can't just
get their hands on all that PHI.
That's not good.
So they came to us to build
them a sanitized pipeline
that their R&D team could
then build models off
to improve their firmware
on these devices.
So after doing a review of
their app architecture--
as I mentioned, Firestore
and Cloud Storage really
helped us move this along.
Four weeks.
Architecture looked a little
bit something like that.
Again, you've got
your medical device.
It landed-- the app
then wrote to Firestore.
So as soon as it wrote
the Firestore document,
we put an on right Cloud
Function trigger on that data
element type in Firestore.
So if that changed, whether
it was a create, an update,
a delete event, really
anything, it would then
trigger this Cloud Function, do
a lookup in the Cloud Storage
to find any related data.
And then if it found
that related data,
it would land a
message on Pub/Sub.
From here, it's all the same.
So it lands into--
Dataflow consumes that
message from Pub/Sub,
performs its ETL--
in this case, removing all
PHI and anonymizing the data
and then landing it in BigQuery
for their analytics team
to do with what they will.
Again, as we look at
these two ETL projects,
hopefully you can start
to see some of the trends
that you saw with
the IoT projects.
With the online
ordering system, Kafka,
it acted as the event trigger.
This is a streaming
job, so any event
trigger that then landed
in Pub/Sub for the message
queue, that then landed
in Dataflow for ETL,
and finally BigQuery
for analytics.
The research and data models.
That Firestore and the
Cloud Function that
acted as the event trigger.
From there, everything's
the same again.
Message queue is Pub/Sub.
Dataflow is your ETL tool.
BigQuery is for analytics.
So again, that might look a
little something like this.
You have your event trigger,
whatever that might be.
Could be a Cloud Function.
Could be the Kafka server.
Could be anything, really.
Then you land it in Pub/Sub.
That's your messaging queue.
From there, you've got your
ETL pipeline and analytics.
Obviously, there's some other
additional analytic options
for analytics.
But as I mentioned
earlier, BigQuery
seems to be the tool of
choice amongst our customers.
So one quick note up here.
You'll see I also put
all the compute options
under ETL pipeline.
If you think back to our
IoT projects, both of those
were also doing ETL with
Cloud Functions and Kub.
So you can roll your own.
Dataflow is a great tool.
It fits your use case, for one.
And two, if you're trying
to get stood up quickly.
But we always have the
option to roll your own.
And the GCP compute services
are a great option for that.
So that's a lot of architecture.
We went through
that kind of fast.
What is this-- well,
what's the point of it all?
So what we're trying
to say is there's
a lot of ways to accomplish
what you're trying to do.
And everyone has
a unique problem.
You all have your own
industry, your own company.
You're facing your
unique issues.
And we don't want
you to walk away
thinking that these are the
only ways to solve the problem,
because there's an
infinite number of ways
that you can go home
and solve your issues.
But what we're trying to
say is that a unique problem
doesn't need to equal
a unique solution.
You saw two examples of two
different companies that
had very different use cases.
But they benefited from the
same underlying architecture.
So reference architectures
are your friends.
There's no shame in using it.
It is tried and tested.
And quite frankly, there is no
extra credit for originality.
So you can save both your
organization time and money.
All right.
So switching gears a little bit.
You might get home from
NEXT, be ready to start down
this journey, a
new project, come
across a list that looks a
little something like this,
and then close your
laptop because you're
a little bit overwhelmed.
So to help curb that
overwhelming feeling,
pass it off to Ray over here.
He's going to talk about
some of these services
that we see most frequently.
[APPLAUSE]
RAY PITMON: Hey, everyone.
I'm Ray.
So that's a big list.
50-plus platform services, APIs.
I think I've got
about 10 minutes.
So we're going to go into a
deep dive, all 50 of them.
Don't worry, I'll talk fast.
You guys ready?
I'm just kidding.
But we are going to discuss
a few of the favorites
that I have and stuff
we use for prototyping.
First thing I'm going to
start with is IoT Core.
It's Google's
managed IoT platform.
Why do I like IoT Core?
Well, it's server-less.
So a few slides back, Patrick
showed the IoT adapter
that we made in RabbitMQ.
That all ran on a
virtual machine.
Required patching
management configuration.
Plus, building a
rabbit cluster that
can handle a million connected
devices is not trivial.
So IoT Core will just scale up.
You can connect as many
devices as you want to it.
So let's talk about some of
the features of IoT Core.
So with IoT Core, it supports
device state configuration
and authentication.
For communication with IoT
Core, you can use MQTT and HTTP.
And we all know about HTTP.
Let's talk about
MQTT for a minute.
So MQTT is a light rate
messaging protocol.
Runs on TCP.
One of the differences
between HTTP and MQTT
is that an MQTT device will
typically make a connection
and hold it open to the server.
So HTTP, usually, a
device will connect,
send a bunch of headers,
negotiate encryption,
and then disconnect.
With MQTT, it holds a connection
open for as long as it can.
Could be hours.
By doing so, you don't
have all that overhead.
So it uses a lot less
data, especially when
you're talking about a
device that maybe you're
paying for cell data on.
And plus, when you have a
device connected via MQTT,
you can push config to it.
So a device is already
subscribed to configuration
or command topics.
And so what you do is you use
an API called int IoT Core,
and it'll push config
directly to the device.
You don't have to
wait for that device
to make it a request
to pull data.
And IoT Core is really, its core
purpose is a protocol bridge.
So when you connect IoT
Core, a device sends data,
it really ends up in Pub/Sub.
So Pub/Sub, it's a managed
real-time messaging service
for GCP.
So an IoT Core device sends
data and ends up in Pub/Sub.
And it's consumed
by your application.
Your application is a
subscriber in Pub/Sub.
So, as I said,
messages are published.
So you publish to
a topic in Pub/Sub.
And again, it doesn't
have to be just IoT Core.
But you can use Pub/Sub
for sending messages
from machine to machine.
So you'd be a publisher
and publish to a topic.
And then you'd have subscribers.
So you have multiple
applications
that could subscribe
to the same topic.
So you can fan out the data,
send it multiple places.
There are other uses of Pub/Sub.
So we use Pub/Sub commonly
to distribute work.
So in one of the other
examples that Patrick had,
he showed Cloud Functions,
daisy-chaining via Pub/Sub.
So you could have one Cloud
Function has a lot of work
to do.
What it can do is it can
publish that to a Pub/Sub topic.
You can have many Cloud
Functions subscribed,
all doing the same thing.
So you end up
scaling horizontally
without doing a lot of work.
So a couple of-- some of the
features important to Pub/Sub
is it's a durable message queue.
So if a message makes
it into Pub/Sub,
it's going to stay there
until you pull it out.
Or, I think it's seven days, it
will eventually throw it away.
It has fan in, fan out support.
So as you can see, you can
have multiple publishers
publishing the same topic.
You can have multiple
subscribers of the same topic.
It's easy to integrate.
There are client libraries
for just about every language.
It's very performant.
And as I said, it's
guaranteed delivery.
So when a message
is published into--
when a message is
pushed into Pub/Sub,
it's waiting for a subscriber.
A subscriber pulls
that message, it
has to acknowledge that
it got the message.
Otherwise, Pub/Sub will
put it back in the queue
and wait for someone
else to grab it.
Are a few caveats
to using Pub/Sub.
The message order
isn't guaranteed.
So if order is important,
you'll have to sort that out
in your subscriber side.
Pub/Sub supports at
least once delivery.
What that means is
that it's guaranteed
to deliver it at least once.
But it could deliver
it more than once.
So you could get duplicates.
You're also limited to 10,000
topics and 10,000 subscriptions
per GCP project.
So because of that,
that's one reason
you wouldn't have an end device
publish directly to Pub/Sub.
You have more than 10,000
devices publishing 10,000
topics, you don't do that.
So that's what you
use IoT Core for.
Next thing I'm going to talk
about is Cloud Function.
So we've been using
Cloud Functions a lot.
Cloud Functions,
obviously they're
server-less, easy to deploy.
You can trigger Cloud Functions
a couple of different ways.
So if you need an HTTP request.
So I think about just a typical
web service, make a request in.
You could also trigger
a Cloud Function
from a file dropped
in Cloud Storage.
So we'll have an
ETL pipeline that
might have a Cloud Function
watching a Cloud Storage
bucket.
File shows up, it's
automatically triggered.
It knows about the file in
that Cloud Storage bucket.
It can grab it and do
some stuff with it.
You can also trigger
it from Pub/Sub.
So one Cloud Function can
subscribe to a Pub/Sub topic.
You can also monitor
a Firestore database.
So it can be
triggered from that.
So data changes in the
Firestore database,
and a Cloud Function can
be activated as well.
So we, in our prototypes, we're
using Cloud Functions for,
as the example he
showed, calling webhooks.
So a Cloud Function
spins up, hits
some other service and
some other cloud provider
or wherever.
Cloud Functions can
easily read and write data
to a Firestore database,
Cloud SQL, BigQuery.
And of course, you
can send data out.
Pub/Sub, you can publish
from Cloud Function
to an external
service or obviously
another Cloud Function.
You can see from the
previous examples
that we use Cloud Functions
all over the place.
Next I'm going to
talk about BigQuery.
So BigQuery, I love BigQuery.
BigQuery is awesome.
If you haven't used BigQuery,
you should use BigQuery.
So one point I like to
make about BigQuery.
You don't need to have
big data to use BigQuery.
So you can have just a
little data and BigQuery.
So it's great, because
who wants to spin up
a SQL server if you have a
task you want to complete.
You need someplace to store
some data and query it later.
BigQuery will work.
You could have 100 rows.
Basically to set up
BigQuery, you go into the UI,
or you could do it via
a command line or API.
You create a data set.
Then you load data into tables.
That's it.
And like many of
the GPC services,
it's pay for what you use.
So for BigQuery, you
pay to query the data.
You get a lot of--
there's a lot of--
you'll see later.
There's a free tier for that.
But it's relatively
inexpensive, especially
with small data sets.
And then you pay a tiny
bit for data storage.
I'm talking pennies per gig.
And there's very little
configuration for a BigQuery.
So you want to make a table,
you define the table schema.
And then you create a table,
and you load data into it.
So a couple of ways to
load data into BigQuery.
You can stream the data in.
So BigQuery supports
streaming at--
you can stream up to 100,000
rows per second into BigQuery.
So, obviously, it's
very performant.
You could also
load via batch job.
So think about taking a
JSON file or a CSV file,
put it into Cloud Storage.
Point at BigQuery.
It'll ingest it and put
it in a table for you.
You query your data out of
BigQuery using standard SQL.
You can use common VI tools.
An example we had was Tableau.
But it works-- if you
walked through here,
you've surely seen 20
different tools that you
can query your data with.
You know, Looker, Data Studio.
You can connect-- you
can use Cloud Datalab.
It connects directly
to BigQuery.
So data scientists,
data engineers
spin up an IPython notebook,
is what Cloud Datalab is.
And that'll connect directly
to BigQuery as well.
So one thing you
wouldn't use BigQuery for
is to store your
data if you're going
to try and drive a website,
like a real-time dashboard.
So one thing you'll learn when
you do a query, it can take--
it's going to take
a couple of seconds.
Doesn't matter if you have
20 rows or 20,000 rows.
It's a couple of seconds
to query that data.
So you wouldn't want to
wait to populate a web
page with data in BigQuery.
You want to run a query
and bring back a report.
So where would I
store my data if we
wanted to have it
available on a web page?
So we use Cloud Firestore a lot.
Works well with Cloud Functions.
It's all integrated.
It's a document database.
So you're storing key
value pairs, NoSQL.
So we'll commonly use that
to store configuration,
application state,
stuff like that.
So it supports
real-time updating too.
So a web developer can
create a dashboard.
And with very little
effort, you can have it
so that if a value
updates in Firestore,
it just automatically
updates in your dashboard.
So you're looking
at a web page, you
don't have to do
anything to pull data.
It automatically
shows updated value.
So we'll use that.
And we're building
dashboards showing
application state or status
or counters, things like that.
We'll use Firestore for that.
You can back up your Firestore
data to Cloud Storage as well.
So Google added
support for that.
So from there, once you have
your Firestone database,
you can back up the
whole thing, pretty much.
You can restore it
back into Firestore.
So you could use that
for disaster recovery.
So not necessarily
that something crashed
and you lost your data.
But more like if somebody--
you overwrote your data
or you deleted it, you maybe
wanted a copy to restore to.
You can do that.
You can also export
that backup to BigQuery.
And we've done that
quite a few times.
So if you have all
this data in Firestore,
you can't really point an
analytics tool at Firestore.
But you can obviously
do it to BigQuery.
So Google has made a feature
of the Firestore backup
is that you can restore
that directly to BigQuery
and do your analytics on it.
And we've got customers
that are doing that.
So another thing we use
a lot, Cloud Storage.
Obviously, Cloud
Storage is used--
most people know about that.
You can store anything in Cloud
Storage as long as it's a file.
So a couple of things
about Cloud Storage
that are interesting.
So it's virtually unlimited.
Store as much as
you want in there.
You just pay for what you use.
Again, it's pennies
per gigabyte.
There is a 5 terabyte
file size limit, though.
So if you have a file
bigger than 5 terabytes,
you're going to
have to cut it up.
It's got 11 nines of durability.
So you're not going to
lose your files that
are in Cloud Storage.
And there are many tools
for managing your data
in Cloud Storage.
So you can use their client
libraries, command line tools,
the Cloud console.
So when you get
back home and you
start spinning up your
projects in the Cloud console,
you can upload
and download files
directly out of Cloud Storage
using the web UI as well.
There are multiple storage
classes in Cloud Storage.
So you may have heard
of the regional buckets,
multiregional.
So when you create a bucket,
you decide what type of bucket
you want, what you want
your storage to be.
So if you pick a
multiregional bucket,
then you store data there,
Google spreads that data out,
stores it, bunch of
POPs all over the place,
and puts the data
closer to your users.
So if you've got users
downloading data,
there'll be less latency there.
You wouldn't necessarily want
to do that if you're doing
analytics workloads, though.
So they also have
a regional bucket.
So you can imagine if
you have a ton of data
you need to process,
you would build your app
to run and deploy it
to, like the US central.
Well, you can deploy your
bucket, data from your bucket,
also in US central.
So it can download fast.
And it costs a little less
when you do regional as well.
So they also have
Nearline, Coldline.
And you've probably
heard of those.
That's for less
frequently accessed data.
We typically wouldn't
use that for a prototype.
You usually store
in that for backup.
So talk a minute
about Cloud SQL.
I like Cloud SQL.
It's not as easy to
set up as BigQuery.
But it's certainly
simple enough.
So we don't use it as much
for prototyping because it's
more configuration.
It's still a great option
to store your data.
Currently, Cloud SQL
supports MySQL and Postgres.
You can have a
SQL server running
in five clicks in the console.
You can go into the
GCP Cloud console.
Five clicks later, you've
got a SQL server running.
Supports all the
stuff you'd expect
from a database service--
high availability,
failover, automated backups,
point in time recovery,
auto storage increase.
And you can have up to
10 terabytes of storage.
You connect to it just
like any other SQL.
So if you've got
an app that needs
to communicate with a
MySQL or Postgres server,
you connect to it the same way
if it's running on Cloud SQL
or if it runs on
a virtual machine
or if it's running
in your data center.
So another thing that we've been
using a lot is Cloud Dataflow.
So Cloud Dataflow is a
fully managed service.
It's supports stream
and batch processing.
So one of the ideas
with Cloud Dataflow
is that if you write your app
correctly in Cloud Dataflow,
you can use the same logic
whether it's streaming data in
or you're doing batch.
So it's server-less.
It's auto-scaling.
So the idea with Cloud
Dataflow is you submit a job.
It'll spin up as many
nodes as it needs to.
It'll work until the job's done.
And then it'll spin them down.
If you're doing streaming,
it obviously won't do that.
It'll keep your streaming
job running forever,
or until you kill it.
So common pattern
for Cloud Dataflow
is to write data
out to BigQuery.
So we showed that previously.
So you can also write data out
to Cloud Storage or Pub/Sub.
And with the example
that we had earlier,
we were using Dataflow to
do data redaction, data
enrichment.
So, in that example,
Dataflow was reading
data out of a BigQuery table.
It was reading flat files
out of Cloud Storage,
combining that data, and then
redacting it and pushing it
back into a different
BigQuery table.
And then, from there, the
guys could do their analytics
on that clean data.
So Firebase Hosting is
another thing we use.
That's pretty straightforward.
All it is is static files.
So if we're building
a dashboard or there's
some web component
to our prototype
we're building for
somebody, you stick
your HTML, JavaScript,
CSS, all that stuff
can go in a Firebase Hosting.
It's really easy
to use, supports
custom domains, all that stuff.
Another thing we're using
is Firebase Authentication.
So authentication isn't easy.
Firebase Authentication
makes it a little easier.
So it's quick and easy
to set up, anyway.
And it's a secure way
to add auth to your app.
So when you're doing a
prototype, a lot of times
you don't want to spend a
ton of time building roles
and permissions and
all the authentication
that you would have
in a full-blown app.
Firebase makes it a
lot easier to do that.
In our case, instead of doing--
so with Firebase, you can do,
there's I don't know
how many different ways
to do authentication and
social and all this stuff.
What we usually do for
a prototype is we'll
just enable username password.
So it's email
password, actually.
So you can go into the console
and put emails and passwords
in.
And Firebase takes care of that.
So they're hashing it and
encrypting and storing it.
Then we use APIs to authenticate
a web app with that.
And, in a lot of cases, we'll
give that Firebase console--
since we're building
these for our customers,
we'll give that project
to the customer.
And the customer can
log into the console
and add their own users to it.
So they've got a UI built in
to do that right in Firebase.
So back to the list.
I obviously didn't go
through all 50 of them.
I just scratched the surface.
I didn't get in a ton of detail.
There's so much-- we could
spend a whole week talking
about this stuff.
But we will use a lot
of these other services
as well, obviously,
if it makes sense.
There are a lot of different
ways to do the same thing.
And for prototypes,
we try and find
the most efficient,
quickest way to do it,
simplest way to do it, so we're
not spending a lot of time
and a lot of money.
It's a big list.
So if you guys want to geek
out about any of these things
later, we can stop by our booth.
I'll be glad to talk to you
about it as much as you want.
So with that, I'm going to
hand it back over to Patrick,
let him talk for a little bit.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MECHURA: All right.
Before I move on to
this next slide here,
one more question for you guys.
Who likes free stuff?
If you don't know about
GCP's free tier, you should.
It's literally free--
hence, free tier.
It's really helpful when you're
testing out a new technology.
You don't have to spend
your own funds on it.
It's a good way to play around
with some of their new services
that they've
announced here today.
If you land on
cloud.google.com/free,
it'll show you a
list of services.
And when I was throwing
this presentation together,
that was the list.
I can't promise that that
is still the same list.
Google reserves the
right to change that.
But you can go there.
It'll show you all the details
of what their free tier is
and some of the caveats.
But a lot of the services
Ray just touched on
that we use in our prototypes
every day are on that list
right now.
So you have Cloud Firestore.
You have Cloud Storage, Pub/Sub,
Cloud Functions, GKE, BigQuery.
So you can get a lot of
value from the free tier
if you're leveraging it.
So a couple of
free tier examples
that I like to touch
on, that I really find
a lot of worth or value in.
Cloud Functions is one of them.
You get 2 million
invocations a month.
That's a lot.
There are limitations on compute
time and some network egress.
But 2 million invocations is
still nothing to scoff at.
The other one would be BigQuery.
Obviously, we have a little
bit of a crush on BigQuery.
But you can run a terabyte
of queries a month.
That's nothing to
scoff at either.
10 gigabyte storage limit.
Still, quite a bit of
data that you can query.
So what's the point
in all of this?
Leverage your free
tiers and leverage
the cloud native services.
All of the services
that Ray went over
and that free tier that
I was just discussing,
they're meant to make
your life easier,
help you save money and
resource hours, something
that I'm sure all of you can
appreciate in your day to days.
And also, it helps you
focus on some more strategic
initiatives.
If you're able to save
that time, and you
start focusing on some
more innovative thoughts
that you and your
team might have.
So that's a lot better
than just focusing
on keeping the lights on.
All right.
Last thing for today.
Dos and don'ts.
So we're consultants, obviously.
We work with a lot
of organizations,
and we get to see both the
good, the bad, and the ugly.
So some of these dos and don'ts
are going to seem like complete
no-brainers.
I wish they were.
They're not always.
So if it is a no-brainer
for you, that's good.
That means you're
doing it right.
But just some things
to keep in mind.
So the first do.
Start with an idea
and formulate a plan.
Simple, right?
Of course.
But it's really easy to
get excited about your idea
and just jump straight into it.
But if you're doing that,
you're probably not going
to end up very successful.
You're going to waste time.
You're going to
waste budget hours.
No one wants that.
So slow down a bit,
define your approach,
figure out your key
use case requirements,
and then take action.
That said, don't
overcomplicate your approach.
It's a PoC, or it's a prototype.
It doesn't need
to be complicated.
So just define it
at a high level.
Define what is going
to look like success.
So, speaking of success, do
define your success criteria.
If you don't define
your success criteria,
how are you going to brag about
being successful to your boss,
to your colleagues, anybody?
It also helps the
rest of your team
stay focused on the end goal.
If you don't have
that success criteria,
how do they know what they
should be focusing on?
One important thing around
that success criteria,
it's not just functional.
There is nonfunctional
requirements as well.
Do you have performance
requirements?
Do you have security
Those are things that
you should be considering
in these prototypes.
But don't confuse a PoC or
your prototype with an MVP.
So prototypes kind of land
in between PoCs and MVPs,
as far as I'm concerned.
Your MVP is meant to be
a Market Viable Product.
So a minimum viable product.
But it's market ready.
PoC is generally
internal-facing.
You're trying to determine
feasibility of it,
maybe test a new technology,
prove something out.
So if their success
criteria are identical,
you should probably
take a step back,
think about why
they're identical,
and figure out which one
you actually need to do.
If you're not proving out a
new concept or new technology,
maybe you don't need
to start with a PoC.
So either way, having the
right success criteria
is key for the last one.
I've already alluded to this.
Set expectations with
your key stakeholders.
There's nothing
worse than getting
to the end of a project,
presenting what you have.
You're excited.
You think it was a
smashing success.
And your stakeholders have
this blank look on their face.
They're confused.
They're wondering where the
features they asked for were.
And it's because you didn't set
their expectations properly,
or at least most likely.
So, if you can talk with
them early and often,
set those expectations on
what you're going to deliver,
when you're going to
deliver it, that's
going to help you
in the long run
to get the reactions
that you want at the end.
The other side of
that coin, don't
be afraid of changing
course or strategy.
I've seen it a
couple of times where
a project owner,
a product owner,
doesn't want to change their
course because they've already
reported to the
stakeholders, this
is how we're going to
do it, and we're not
going to do it any other way.
But they get down
that path, they
realize it's not
a viable strategy.
And they still continue
down that path.
You're wasting time and money.
That's not good for you, and
it's not good for your company.
What you really should
be doing at that point
is pausing, reassessing
your other options,
resetting expectations
with your stakeholders,
and changing your course.
The whole point of
a PoC or prototype
is to determine feasibility.
So if you find out
that it's not feasible,
there's no point in
continuing down that path.
That leads to the
last point of the day.
Have a plan, communicate
it, and take action.
The last one is key as well.
Take action.
A lot of projects fail
because they haven't started.
So don't forget that last one.
So this is about
wrapping it up for us.
Just a couple of key points.
We've already touched on this.
But if you learn nothing
else from us today,
hopefully these can
stick in your head.
Number one, unique problems.
They don't have to
be unique solutions.
Use reference architectures.
They're your friend.
Leverage the free tiers
and cloud native services
to help you save money and time.
And then have a plan,
communicate that criteria,
and take action.
[APPLAUSE]